Good morning, Hank! it's Wednesday.
So, Sarah and I know the tunes to a lot of lullabies but we don't know the words to any of those lullabies.
Which has necessitated us coming up with our own lyrics.
Nowhere is this phenomenon weirder
than in the list of things
that daddy is going to buy Henry
in the event that the mockingbird doesn't sing.
♪ Hush little baby, don't say a word ♪
♪ Daddy's gonna buy you a mockingbird ♪
♪ And if that mockingbird don't sing ♪
♪ Daddy's gonna buy you a diamond ring ♪
♪ And if that diamond ring don't shine ♪
♪ Well, daddy's gonna buy you a case of wine ♪
♪ And-if-because-you're-an-infant-and-not-allowed-to-drink-that wine should go sour ♪
♪ Daddy's gonna buy you a superpower ♪
♪ And if that superpower proves corrupting ♪
♪ Daddy's gonna buy a volcano erupting ♪
♪ And if that eruption produces too much ash ♪
♪ Daddy's gonna buy you a diaper rash ♪
♪ And if that diaper rash ♪ actually.... isn't.. desirable and besides that can't be bought.
♪ Well, daddy's gonna buy you some polka dots ♪
*kiss kiss* (mwah~~)
Polka dots!
♪ And if those polka dots aren't your style ♪
♪ Daddy's gonna buy a Pacific Isle ♪
♪ And if that Pacific Isle.. is in fact-way-too-expensive
for-daddy-to-purchase
and-he-defaults-on-his-loan
and-gets-foreclosed-upon
Daddy's gonna buy you the Sultanate of Oman ♪
♪ And if, given the fact that daddy couldn't afford a tiny island, ♪
-his promise to buy you a sovereign nation is plainly silly-
♪ Daddy's gonna buy you some waterlilies ♪
♪ And if those water lilies ever should wilt ♪
♪ Daddy's gonna buy you a hand-knit quilt  ♪
♪ And if after all that you still weep ♪
♪ Daddy's gonna have to grapple-with-the-fact-that-
♪ while-buying-goods-and-services-
♪ may-benefit-the-economy
♪ it's-not-necessarily-the-best-way-to-get.
♪ babies~ to~ sleep. ♪
(mwah!)
*nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom*
(mh mwah!)
Hank, I'll see you on Friday :)
(Epic outro ft. flying baby) *trumpet sounds*  dotototdo~ dododotodo~ ah dodododo~~ do ah dodododo~~ do!
dododo dotodo~~~
CHHAJAJAJAAA AA~~
*hu :)*